THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO
ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE I WILL
START OFF AS A SUB COMMITTEE TO
KEEP THE- TO KEEP THE-
PRESENTATION OF MOVING THAT
THAT'S OKAY WITH THEIR WHITE
EVERYONE. AND A GOOD AFTERNOON-
WITNESSES WILL BE ALLOWED TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON OR BY PHONE.
THE NUMBER TO CALL IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THE. FIFTEEN FIVE ZERO
ELEVEN ZERO ZERO THIS NUMBER CAN
ALSO BE FINE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND IS DISPLAYED ON YOUR
SCREEN. FOR THOSE CONTENT MAKE
SURE THAT YOU PLEASE MUTE
YOURSELF. WHILE YOU'RE WAITING
TO ELIMINATE ANY BACKGROUND
NOISE. A BRIEF BILL HEARD TODAY
THAT WOULD OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO
WITNESSES AT THE PORT. TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EACH.
WITNESS WOULD BE PROVIDED TO-
MINUTES. FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CALLING AND YOU'LL BE
PLACED UNTIL THE OPPORTUNE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PORT
OPPOSITIONAL WILL BE ALTERNATED
- WHEN IT'S YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO
UNMUTE YOURSELVES IN ORDER TO
SPEAK. PLEASE BE BRIEF LIMIT
YOURSELF ONLY TO NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY-
WITHOUT WILL BEGIN A COUPLE
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS- AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT CHOI HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR I THINK
THIS CAN THINK COMMITTEE
CONSISTS OF FOUR MEASURES. AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FOUR- GIPSON AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX OF THE
ARGO AB TWENTY TWELVE- BIGELOW.
TWENTY AB TWENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
SANTIAGO AND FILL OUT KILEY
ASKED FOR A MOTION ONCE WE HAVEA QUORUM IN THE MEANTIME I SEE
ONE OF THE AUTHORS IS HERE MR
STONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN. A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THIS MIGHT NOT ON. THAT AREA.
FOR I WAS A QUORUM. WE NOW HAVE
A QUORUM PRESENT MEN SECRETARY.
SANTIAGO HERE BIGELOW AT
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN BRIAN
COOLEY. COOPER DOLLY DALY DAVIES
GARCIA GIPSON. JONES SAWYER GO
LACKING HERE LOW. MATHIS YOUR-
QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS YOUR- RIVAS.
RUBIO SALAS. SMITH. INCLUDE I.
MISTER CURTIS HERE. I THINK IT
IS SO YOU MAY PROCEED. FOR YOU
WITH OTHER LABELING BILL WE DO
THIS COUPLE YEARS AGO FOR
MONTEREY AND THIS IS FOR THE
SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS. BEING ABLE
TO DESIGNATE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAIN
WINDS IS THE IMPORTANT
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FOR
CERTAIN REGIONS- UNFORTUNATELY
WE NEED TO COME ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THIS NAPA
SONOMA MONTEREY MENDOCINO EACH
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DESIGNATE AS
LONG AS THERE'S A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF GRAPES IN THE
WINE. THAT THEY ARE FROM THAT
PARTICULAR LOCALE WE'RE ASKING
TO ADD SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS TO
THAT LIST OF THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS CAN BE IDENTIFIED AS
IT IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
WINEGROWING REGIONS IN. THE
THANK YOU IN THE STATE. WE HAVE
A FIRST AND SECOND. THANK YOU N.
WITH ME IS CAKEY MCKAY FROM THE
SANTA CRUZ WINEGROWERS
ASSOCIATION WHO SHOULD BE WITH
US ON THE PHONE SPEAKING SUPPORT. THIS ROBBERIES PHARMACY
OPERATOR. HE IS OKAY TANTAMOUNT
LANGER DISTRIBUTION EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
TESTIMONY. WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE AND THIS
INCREASE OF THE COMPETITIVE
MARKET BUILDING AWARENESS FOR
THE SENATE COULD NOT MAYBE AND
THE RIGHT WINE REGIONS ARE ABA
IS CRUCIAL TO OUR GRAPE GROWERS
AND VINTNERS IN A LOT OF THIS
ISSUE BILL NOT THE PATIENT
QUALITY IN AN INCREASINGLY
COMPETITIVE GLOBAL WINE MARKET.
AND EVERY COULD WILL RECOGNIZE
BOTTLE OF WINE. PRODUCE FROM TAX
GREAT. IT THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION. UNLESS THAT
WAS THE ONLY WITNESS CORRECT
THOSE MAINLY WITH. ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- THEY WILL
PROCEED TO THE PHONE IN CASE
THERE'S ANY- OR IN PERSON IF
THERE'S ANY- SUPPORT. AB ON THE
PHONE FOR SUPPORT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ANY OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY
I'LL TAKE THAT AS A NO
OPPOSITION COMMENTS AS WELL. I
WILL FIRST THE SECOND- THE
AUTHOR IS WELCOME TO CLOSE ON
THE BILL I ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU- MANAGED HAVING THE
FIRST THE SECOND IS ANY
COMMITTEE COMMENTS. QUESTIONS
MASSACRE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SANTIAGO HI BIGELOW AGIR CURRY
BERMAN FRAN I FULLY. COOPER
DOLLY DALY DAVIES. GARCIA GIPSON
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE LOW.
MATHIS MATHIS III QUIRK-SILVA.
RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SALAS SMITH SMITH I. WE HAVE THE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN THANK
MISTER THANK YOU MEMBERS AT LET
LET SOMEONE WAS RIGHT OVER THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE WILL
BE A FIRST SECOND AND A THIRD
AMMANFORD CURRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN. BRIAN I AND I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
DALI DALI I DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES. GARCIA GIPSON. JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
AYE LUCKY I LOW MATHIS. MATHIS
I. QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS RAMOS I
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH
SMITH I. AND JUST TO REMIND
FOLKS WHO MAY BE ON THE PHONE.
A. B. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
BY MISTER CHOI. HAS BEEN PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. FOR THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY WAITING AROUND FOR
A BILL THAT'S NOT BEING HEARD
THANK YOU- I'M GOING BY ORDER
HERE- MISTER JONES SAWYER ARE
YOU READY. WE HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ARE
I AM HERE TODAY PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE JUNE TO JUNE
T. STATE HOLIDAY ACT FOR THOSE
WHO MAY NOT KNOW JUNETEENTH IS
THE ANNUAL CELEBRATION OF JUNE.
NINETEENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
WHEN WORD OF FREEDOM REACHED THE
LAST AND SLATE BLACK PEOPLE IN
GALVESTON BAY TEXAS THE FINAL
CONFEDERATE STATE WITH SLAVERY
IN PLACE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION WAS ISSUED BY
PRESIDENT ABRAHAM LINCOLN AFTER
TWO LONG YEARS AND EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE THE BELL OF FREEDOM
RANG TRUE FOR OVER THREE MILLION
BLACK AMERICANS. THAT DAY MARKED
THE BEGINNING OF A FIGHT TO
PROVIDE FAIR AND EQUAL TREATMENT
FOR THE FORMALLY AS SLAVES TODAY
JUNE NINETEENTH SERVES AS A
REMINDER THAT EQUALITY IS NOT
ACCOMPLISHED OVERNIGHT. IN
RECENT YEARS WE HAVE WITNESSED
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS BY BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE TO HISTORY AND
ADDRESS THE PLIGHT OF THE BLACK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY DESPITE THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE WE
STILL HAVE A LONG LONG WAY TO
GO. THE JUNE TWO STATE HOLIDAY
ACT BUILDS UPON THE MOMENTUM
FROM THIS PAST YEAR WHEN THE U.
S. CONGRESS APPROVED A MEASURE
TO THAT MADE THIS DAY A FEDERAL
HOLIDAY. S. IMPACT PRICE THESE
RESOLUTIONS MAY BE THIS DAY IN
AMERICAN HISTORY DESERVES ITS
PROPER RESPECT UNDER AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY FIVE WILL OFFICIALLY
BECOME A PAID HOLIDAY FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES DURING THE LIKES OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR IT'S A
SEARCH SERVICE DAY. OUR ABC
THIRTY FIVE HAVE CALIFORNIA
JOINED OTHER STATES ARE ALREADY
OBSERVE JUNETEENTH AS A PAID
STATE HOLIDAY SUCH AS TEXAS. NEW
YORK VIRGINIA WASHINGTON AND
ILLINOIS. MORE SIGNIFICANTLY
THIS BILL WILL MARK IN HISTORY A
MOMENT THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
REFLECT UPON BLACK AMERICAN
HISTORY AND A BAY AREA STEP
PERSIST IN OUR COMMUNITY TO THIS
DAY. S. NAOMI RAINEY PIERSON. OF
THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE OF AN ACP JOINS US
TODAY OVER THE PHONE AS A CO
SPONSOR TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. YOUR TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT IS COSPONSORED
CENTER BARRIER BARREIRO WITH B.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER-
WE'LL BEGIN WITH YOUR FIRST
WITNESS. EMPTY THE SECOND ONE IS
A TWO MINUTE THE TIME THANK YOU
. THAT. WITH A MAN MISTER
OPERATOR TO GO TO MISTER.
OPERATOR JUST EIGHTY IN THE
OPERATION. YES HELLO CAROLYN.
AND WHAT PERSON ARE WE LOOKING
FOR IN THE CALL NAOMI RAINEY
PIERSON. IF WE MAY HAVE OUR
MAILING RAINY PEARSON PRESS. ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TEN NINE EIGHT
SEVEN SIX FIVE FOUR THREE GET
ONE. THE MOMENT PLEASE.
MISS PEARSON YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS NAOMI RANDY PETERSON AND
I'M REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
HAWAII STATE CONFERENCE NAACP.
ON BEHALF OF OUR PRESIDENT. DR
RUTHCALENDAR CALIFORNIA SAY
CONFERENCE OF THE NAACP
REPRESENTING FIFTY SEVEN
BRANCHES TWENTY THREE YOUTH
COUNCIL STATE HWY I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE
COMMEMORATING JUNETEENTH AS A
PET. PAID STATE HOLIDAY.
JUNETEENTH JUNE NINETEENTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE IS THE
OLDEST KNOWN DEVELOPED
CALIBRATION THAT SYMBOLIZES THE
END OF LABRIE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND SERVES AS A
HISTORICAL MILESTONE TO REMIND
AMERICANS OF THOSE WHO SUCCUMB
TO THE CRUELTY OF SLAVERY THE
END OF SLAVERY IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
TRIUMPH OVER IN STATEMENT. ALL
PRESIDENT ISSUED DIEM.
PROCLAMATION ON JANUARY THE
FIRST EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE
DECLARING ALL IN SLOWLY PEOPLE
FORTY ON PAPER MOST AFRICAN
AMERICANS WERE NOT AWARE OF
THEIR FREEDOM. FOR TWO YEARS.
THEN PUT IT ACTION RECOGNIZES
AFRICAN AMERICANS AS A WHOLE
PERSON INSTEAD OF 3% OF A PERSON
. UP THE QUICKLY HELLO FOR
COOLEY TO VOTE. SUPPOSED IN THE
POLITICAL. I BELIEVE FORMER
OWNERS SEEK THEIR OWN AND USE
PUBLIC A CAP ACCOMMODATIONS. AND
TO THOUSAND OAKS THREE GOVERNOR
DAVIS SIGNED INTO LAW SB EIGHT
TWELVE BILLION SINCE THE CLAIM
IN THE THIRD SATURDAY IN JUNE
EACH YEAR TO BE KNOWN AS
JUNETEENTH NATIONAL FREEDOM DAY
A DELIBERATE SERVANTS. THANK YOU
URGES ALL. TO HONOR AND REFLECT
ON THE SIGNIFICANT ROLES THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE PLAYED IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES
AND HOW AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN WHICH SOCIETY. THROUGH
THEIR STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
INEQUALITY. ON JUNE. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BIETEN SIGNED
INTO LAW JUNETEENTH NATIONAL
INDEPENDENCE DAY AS A U. S.
FEDERAL HOLIDAY COULD MENTION
GRADING. END OF SLAVERY THE
UNITED STATES. SB. SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE HAVE A CALIFORNIA JOINED
STATES SUCH AS TEXAS NEW YORK
VIRGINIA WASHINGTON AND ILLINOIS
IN RECOGNIZING JUNETEENTH. AARON
HOLIDAY. IN RECENT ALSO
JUNETEENTH. HOLIDAY INN CAL
CIENCIAS OF SHADOWS AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND RUNNING IN THE OVER
THREE IS MAKE SURE YOU A SECOND
ONE IF NOT WE'LL CONTINUE. DON'T
HAVE SECOND WOULD CONTINUE HER
APOLOGIZE. POLICE TO CALL OUT TO
BE A AND- COMMITTEE TOOK THE HI
I'M THIS IMPORTANT MAY. TO
COMMIT SURVEYED THE AND THE
PLAYED. THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE
WILL ASK- IF THERE'S ANY. IS ANY
OPPOSITION WE WOULD ALSO EXTEND
TWO MINUTES EACH- IF THERE'S ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN PERSON. A
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND I'LL GO TO THE PHONES IN
THE SAME THING I IF THERE'S ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE OPERATOR THANK YOU MISTER
STE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CURTIS PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
CONNELLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DOUG SERVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION AT
THE WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA
WEST IN SUPPORT THANKS. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON KATE EITHER
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE. AS THE
OPERATOR HOLD FOR A SECOND ACT
AND- FOR OPPOSITION IN CASE
THERE IS ANY- AND I WENT A
LITTLE BIT QUICKER THAN I SHOULD
HAVE AND I MISSED TWO PEOPLE WHO
WERE- IN PERSON IN SUPPORT OF.
IT YOU YOU MAY PROCEED NOW NAME
ORGANIZATION THIS ONLY THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A
SHANNON SWANSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHNSON PRASAD FROM
THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICORP **** AND
WE ARE IN HIGH SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU BACK TO THE OPERATOR
AND CASES ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS ALLEN HOW DOES NOT
APOLOGIES AND WHAT THEY WERE TO
GET OUT OF THE PORT LINE BUT
RIGHT HERE IN SUPPORT FOR NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA. ANYONE ELSE AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT. I'M
SORRY WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN Q. FOUR AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A FIRST
OR SECOND ALREADY AND IF THERE'S
ANY COMMENTS BY MEMBERS OR
QUESTIONS. I WOULD WELCOME THE
NOW. NOT SEEN ANY I TWENTY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE FORD- MISTER JONES
SAWYER WOULD KINDLY ASK TO BE. A
TO BE RICK TO REQUESTED A CO
AUTHOR THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. YES
TO BE HONEST HAVE YOU ON THANK
YOU- SEEING NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS-
BENEFITTED HER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION. SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO
AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN. RYAN RYAN AYE COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
DOLLY DOLLY I DAILY DAILY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES AYE GARCIA. GIPSON
JONES SAWYER I JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE LOW. LOW
AYE MATHIS MATHIS II QUIRK-SILVA
. RAMOS. I WILL BE. RAMOS I'D
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
SMITH SMITH I. THE MEASURE
POSSIBLE KEEP IT OPEN FOR ADDING
MEMBERS- MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
DANCER.
NICE SCREEN SHARES HER.
RODRIGUEZ. WE ARE FIRST IN A
SECOND THANK YOU THANK YOU ONE
OF MY DESERVE AVOCADOS YEAH. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FIRST AND
FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE SAFF FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH MY OFFICE AND OUR
SPONSORS. AB TWENTY THREE OH
THREE IS A BI PARTISAN EFFORT
THAT CONTINUES TO PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA BRAND OR REQUIRING
THAT ONLY A GABI SPIRITS
PRODUCED ENTIRELY FROM AGAVES
GROANING WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT FLAVORING OR COLORING
ADDITIVES ARE LABELED WITH THE
WORDS CALIFORNIA AGAVE SPIRITS
OR ANY COMBINATION OF THE WORDS.
OF CALIFORNIA QUICKLY
ESTABLISHED HIMSELF AS A
PRODUCER OF HIGH QUALITY AGAVE
SPIRITS WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THERE IS NO OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OUR REPUTATION AND
CAUSE CONSUMER CONFUSION AND
UNFAIR COMPETITION. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT
FOR MULTIPLE ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE GUY OF IT IN THE GARBAGE
INDUSTRY. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS CRAIG REYNOLDS THE
SPONSOR AND FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA GABI COUNCIL AND
CHRIS STELLAR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL
DISTILLERS GUILD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE IT- I AM
CRAIG REYNOLDS AND FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA GOT A
COUNCIL- SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
WERE A COALITION OF AGAVE
GROWERS I GOT A DISTILLER'S
RETAILERS AND CONSUMERS WHO HAVE
COME TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THIS
EMERGING INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA-
I'LL KEEP THIS BRIEF CALIFORNIA
IS NOW THE ONLY STATE PRODUCING
YOU HAVE A SPIRITS FROM AGAVES
GROWN THE UNITED STATES OUR
CRAFT DISTILLERS HAVE PROVEN.
THEIR ABILITY TO PRODUCE HIGH
QUALITY SPIRITS USING CALIFORNIA
GROWN AGAVES- THE HIGH STANDARDS
SET FORTH IN THIS BILL INSURE
THAT OUR CONSUMERS GET WHAT THEY
EXPECT WHEN THEY SEE CALIFORNIA
ON THERE GOT A SPIRITS BOTTLES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
IN PROCEED TO THE NEXT WITNESS.
THEY PRESS THE BUTTON HERE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRYSTAL AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL
DISTILLERS GUILD I'M ALSO THE
OWNER OF AMADOR DRY DIGGINGS
DISTILLERY UP IN EL DORADO HILLS
. SO ON BOTH CASES WE WELCOME
THIS BILL AND THE CLARIFICATION
SO THAT AS WE MAKE CALIFORNIA
GOV A PRODUCTS WE CAN PROUDLY
MARKET AND ADVERTISE TO THE
WORLD. THAT THIS PRODUCT IS A
HUNDRED PERCENT- GROWN AND
DISTILLED HEARING CALIFORNIA
MAKES US PROUD TO KNOW THAT SO
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR SANTIAGO
AND ARE AUTHOR. THANK YOU THAT
WAS SHORT SWEET- FOR ANY IN CASE
WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO
IS IN OPPOSITION WE WOULD ALSO.
INVITE THEM TO SPEAK. ASCENA
WILL GO TO- WILL GO TO WILL GO
TO- IN PERSON. OUR SUPPORT. I'LL
GO TO IN PERSON OPPOSITION IF
THERE IS ANY. AND I'LL JUMP TO
THE PHONE FOR ANY IN PERSON FOR
ANY ON THE PHONE SUPPORT.
OPERATOR YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE. OH THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE OH THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
LINE NUMBER.
I'M SORRY WE NOT HAVE ANY. WHAT
WE DO ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS RAIN THE
GARCIA PROGRESS UNIFORMS
ALTHOUGH FEES MAKABE GROWERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NINE FOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE OH THREE AT THIS
TIME ANY OPPOSITION SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
OH THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE OH
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN THE
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE OH
THREE. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OTHER MEDIA MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NOT SEEING ANY. FIVE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR BY CHANCE
BEFORE WE TAKE THIS TREMENDOUS
VOTE IS THERE ANY CHANCE THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE AND ARE FOR ALL
OF US TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A SMELL OR TASTE OF THIS
PRODUCT. WELL IF YOU LIKE TO
COME UP TO MY OFFICE YOU'RE MORE
THAN WELCOME OFFERS A QUICK
TASTY SO I'M NOT SURE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO COME ON UP I AM
CONFIDENT THAT THE AUTHOR MEANT
THAT ALL OF THIS- WE WOULD
CHOOSE. COULD COME TO HER OFFICE
AFTER THIS IMPORTANT VOTE. I
HAVE A TASTING AND I SMELL
ABSOLUTELY YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO COME BY. I THINK THE
VICE CHAIR SUGGESTED THAT WE
TABLE THIS BILL UNTIL WE-
ADEQUATELY. UNDERSTOOD THE
CONTENT FOR THE PRODUCT THAT'S
WHAT I HEARD. THANK. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE DAILY SHOW THEM.
WE I CAN TAKE A HINT YEAH. WE'LL
TAKE A MOMENT PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
TO SAY THAT YES ICE I SERVED ON
INSURANCE THIS MORNING AND IT
WILL IT WILL IT WAS ONE OF THE
MOST. INSIGHTFUL AND FUN
COMMITTEE THAT I HAVE EVER BEEN
ON THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
UP. THAT WE HAVE A FIRST THE
SECOND THE IT WOULD BE FOR A
MEASURE HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE AND MANAGER PLEASE
CALL ROLE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY C. AGUIAR-CURRY
C. BERMAN. BRIAN BRIAN I COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER AYE
DALI DALI I DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES AYE GARCIA. GIPSON
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS III
QUIRK-SILVA. RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS. SALAS I MET.
SMITH I. HAS THE BOTH LEAVE IT
OPEN FOLLOWING THE LEAD OF THE
AUTHOR MUCH OF DRESSES ASSEMBLY
STIR I GOT CURRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CURRY GOOD
THANK YOU. LEAVE THE DOOR OPEN
THANK YOU NOT. A MASSACRE IF YOU
CAN HAVE OF THOSE WHO MAY HAVE
MISSED A COUPLE BOOKS COULD BE
ADDED ON. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BERMAN. DAVIES. AB IS
AYE GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
LOW. LOW I QUIRK-SILVA. SALAS
SALAS I. IN FACT CALENDARS UP.
FILE ITEM ONE. AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN STONE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN. DAVIES
DAVIES UYGHUR CM GIPSON. GIPSON
I LOW. LOW I QUIRK-SILVA. SALAS
SALAS I. BUILDOUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
BERMAN GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON HI
QUIRK-SILVA. EIGHTEEN IT'S UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. EVERYBODY
WAS YEAH. AS EIGHTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN IF ANYONE COMES. I
AGREE.
RIGHT ONE JERRY. EXACTLY.
YEAH.
I THINK. TAKEN. YEAH. HI MY NAME
YEAH. LATER ON. YEAH WELL. THE
SAME OUT OF SCHOOL.
WELL.
MR BERMAN IS PRESENT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CAST YOUR VOTE ON THE
BILL'S. AND SECRETARY COULD YOU
HELP MISTER PER. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BERMAN HI BERMAN I.
FILE ITEM ONE AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
BERMAN I. FILE ITEM TO AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION BERMAN. BERMAN
HI FILE ITEM. FOR AB TWENTY
THREE OH THREE AGUILAR CURRY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN BERMAN HI THIS BERMAN FOR
THE RECORD YOU HAVE BEEN
CORDIALLY INVITED AS MANY OF THE
MEMBERS TO MISS I KERRY'S
OFFICE- OR A SAMPLING OR A SMELL
OF WHAT THE PRODUCT IS LIKE SO
YOU ARE FULLY INFORMED ON. THE
PRODUCT I LOOK. WHAT FOR TODAY
THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.